hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar heart failure a global
challenge from prognosis to management
I'm Suzy Valdez of lab routes and I'll
be your moderator for this session
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab routes the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by Abbott
Abbott Abbott helps people live their
best life through the power of Health
for more than 125 years they've brought
new products and technologies to the
world in nutrition Diagnostics medical
devices and branded generic
pharmaceuticals that create more
possibilities for more people at all
stages of life today 94,000 Abbott team
members are working to help people live
not just longer but better in more than
150 countries to learn more about our
sponsor please go to wwe.com so let's
get started you can pose questions to
speakers during our presentation while
they fresh in your mind to do so simply
type them into the drop down box located
on the far left of your screen labeled
ask a question and click the send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of your presentation window
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of your presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the answer a question box located on the
far left of your screen also we will be
conducting some polls during this
presentation and would really appreciate
your participation the polls will pop up
in your slide window when it pops up
please click on the answer that best
reflects your work thank you again for
participating in advance this is an
educational web sim webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education credit
tab located at the top right of your
presentation window and
all the process for obtaining your
credits I'd now like to present today's
speaker dr. Peter McCullough
dr. McCullough is a vice chief of
medicine at Baylor University Medical
Center in Dallas Texas and a principal
faculty member in internal medicine for
Texas A&M University Health Science
Center his internationally recognized
authority on the role of chronic kidney
disease as a cardiovascular risk State
with over 1,000 publications including
the interface between renal disease and
cardiovascular illness in Braun Wald's
heart disease textbook dr. McCulloh is a
recipient of a Simon deck award from the
American College of Cardiology and
international of is ENSO award in
critical care nephrology for his
scholarship and research he is also the
founder and current president of the
Kearney o renal Society of America his
work has appeared in the New England
Journal of Medicine the Journal of
American Medical Association and other
top-tier journals worldwide he is a
co-editor of reviews in cardiovascular
medicine associated editor of American
Journal of Cardiology and serves on the
editorial boards of multiple specialty
journals dr. McCall is complete bio can
be found at our website lab route site
lab routes comm please join me now in
welcoming our presenter dr. McCulloh you
may now begin your presentation sir
welcome I want to start out by thanking
you for that introduction in thanking
our sponsor today as well as all of you
who have joined the call for this
important webinar titled heart failure a
global challenge from prognosis to
management and I just want to say as an
opener that heart failure is our most
important diagnosis from a
hospitalization perspective in the
United States it's a leading cause of
hospitalization and a central focus on
internal medicine physicians hospitalist
cardiologists hospital administrators
and many others with respect to this
really chronic disease pandemic that we
are facing our topic today will bring up
important
points with respect to the clinical
laboratory and its role in heart failure
so with that I want to give a disclosure
that this speaker program is sponsored
by and on behalf of Abbott and the
content of the presentation is
consistent with all applicable FDA
requirements
I have received consulting fees from
Abbott Diagnostics in the past so I'll
follow this outline and make a few
comments with respect to each one of
these bullet points and get us opened up
to the idea of heart failure discuss the
challenges that the syndrome presents
get into the utility of natural peptides
these important diagnostic as well as
prognostic and management tools that we
have and then present collect in three
that may be a particular test or an
essay that you are less familiar with
and then wrap it up with conclusions
well what is heart failure it's
certainly not a good term to use with
patients patients are always concerned
many hospitals have heart failure
services and they really struggle with
this and have tried to change to heart
success services or use some other type
of term but what we know is that a
definition of heart failure a modern
definition would be that heart failure
is a complex clinical syndrome that can
result from any structural functional
cardiac disorder that impairs the
ability of the left ventricle to fill or
a check with blood because not all
patients have volume overload at the
time of initial or subsequent evaluation
the term heart failure is preferred over
the older term congestive heart failure
and I think that's an important
take-home point we use the abbreviation
HF as opposed to CHF now of all the
heart failure types that exist we can
divide them into about half our patients
who have a reduced left ventricular
ejection fraction the left ventricular
ejection fraction is the amount of blood
that's ejected with each beat of the
heart from the left ventricle out into
the aorta and what you need to know is
that about half of patients have a
reduced left ventricular ejection
fraction a normal value is 55 to 75
percent the blood is ejected with each
beat and when it's below 45 percent
experts would agree that it's reduced
ejection fraction about half of patients
though the ejection fraction is
served and so we use this term reduced
and preserved lve F now the ejection
fraction is determined by cardiac
ultrasound echocardiography can be
determined by nuclear scintigraphy can
be determined by cardiac catherization
but it's a core measure that all
hospitals know the left ventricular
ejection fraction by these imaging
studies for not only management of heart
failure but also patients after
myocardial infarction of those with
reduced ejection fraction about two
thirds have an ischemic etiology meaning
they've had a prior heart attack and
damage to the heart about a third or
considered non-ascii m'q of those with
preserved ejection fraction about 25
percent of patients have superimposed
ischemia and we don't understand its
importance in terms of its contribution
to the left ventricular dysfunction but
75% of that subgroup have no evidence of
ischemia
when subject to stress testing what we
know is that heart failure with
preserved ejection fraction is difficult
because here the ejection fraction is
normal or near-normal and that when we
look in a large clinical trial like this
one the I preserve trial that you can
see about 45% of patients have no
evidence of left ventricular hypertrophy
that about 34% have a normal left atrial
size and 31% have normal diastolic
parameters on the Doppler examination so
heart failure with preserved ejection
fraction really can't be established
with echocardiography alone it's a
clinical syndrome that's very much
dependent on support from the clinical
laboratory years ago I published the
largest heart failure study in the world
called the reach study and it had nearly
30,000 patients that were followed over
ten years and what we demonstrated was
clearly the incidence of heart failure
was age dependent as you can see in the
left hand panel where individuals as
they go from below age 65 all the way
through greater than 85 have a
progressively higher incidence rate men
and women are pretty close
and then what you can see on the
right-hand panel is that the age of
diagnosis is strongly related to
survival as a general rule heart failure
has a 5-year 50% survival and has only a
10% 10-year survival the vast majority
of patients about 90% of patients with
heart failure will die of heart failure
and the mode of death is either pump
failure or sudden electrical arrhythmia
rhythmic death but we always teach the
students and how staff and others nurses
that when a patient has heart failure
that that should be the number-one
diagnosis on the problem list since it
will dominate the patient's healthcare
utilization and it will be very likely
the cause of death in the end now the
American Heart Association has stages of
heart failure stages a B C and D and
that really has to do with a
consideration of the where a patient is
in the heart failure continuum stage a
means there's no manifestations of heart
failure but risk factors are present
such as hypertension or structural heart
disease stage B is where patients have a
reduced ejection fraction but they don't
yet have symptoms stage C is symptomatic
heart failure with as Cardinal features
of shortness of breath peripheral edema
and fatigue and stage D heart failure is
considered terminal heart failure we
know that in the guidelines suggest that
early in recognition and treatment are
the key if we diagnose heart failure
early and we start appropriate therapy
we can markedly change the outcome in
patients our pharmaceuticals and devices
really do work particularly for low
ejection fraction heart failure we have
over 12 forms of therapies that can be
applied that reduce hospitalization or
death unfortunately we don't have the
same for heart failure with preserved
ejection fraction and then largely
end-of-life care really matters here we
oftentimes involve hospice or palliative
care in the very end stages of disease
now what are the challenges that exist
with heart failure given what we know
well the total population is estimated
at about 6.5 million and there's nearly
a million new
cases per year you can see that 50%
five-year survival and the overall costs
which are really large the major cost
driver though is the incidence of
hospitalization it's really not our
utilization of drugs or devices
therapies imaging diagnostics or
laboratory Diagnostics in the clinic
those are all very small in comparison
to the cost of hospitalization so it's
always been said the goal and heart
failure is to avoid these
hospitalizations it's a burden for
patients because of congestive symptoms
activity limitation the abnormal heart
rhythms these recurrent hospitalizations
and reduce survival the majority of my
patients with heart failure
unfortunately go on medical disability
or medical retirement and really are
busy with their hospital visits and
medical therapy you can see is projected
by 2037 that we're going to have about
10 million individuals with heart
failure in the projections from my
original reach study are being applied
here that we're really on the ascending
limb of a curve primarily because the
age structure of the United States is
changing to a more elderly population
the lifetime risk of heart failure is
about one in five for men and women and
and it's largely driven through the
principal risk factors of hypertension
and coronary heart disease both of those
root causes have a large preventive
aspect to it so with perfect blood
pressure control and perfect coronary
heart disease risk factors one could
guide themselves to a much lower risk of
heart failure over the course of their
life prognosis I've already mentioned
with respect to survival over time about
40 to 60 percent of patients do have
very severe symptoms that are limiting
them you can see that the prognosis of
patients is similar to that of patients
with certain cancers and although we
have a much different approach to
patients with cancer
in terms of our exes to services and our
general empathy it's important to
realize that a diagnosis of heart
failure is about as severe as many solid
organ cancers the long-term tenth trends
in heart failure survival are somewhat
favorable and you can see here that
there's progressively lower rate ratios
for the incidence of heart failure in
men and in particularly in women so we
are making progress with respect to
blood pressure control and other risk
factors attenuating this graduation rate
to heart failure you can see here that
the overall temporal trends and the age
adjusted mortality rates are not
changing over time and this suggests
that once the patients have a diagnosis
of heart flare we haven't been moving
the needle with respect to mortality now
the survival trends in heart failure can
also be looked at in terms of age or Cal
and I'm sorry a calendar temporal
periods from 1987 you can see forward to
2001 at least during that period
unfortunately it was stagnant with a lot
of developments and so we didn't see an
improvement in survival now in a
hospital length of stay is about 6.2
days and the mortality rates 4.1%
possible Mia readmission rates are about
20% in 30 days this is a key metric
because hospitals that are above a
moving average here do receive a penalty
for Medicare if this occurs but 50% of
patients are hospitalized at six months
and you can see the longer-term
mortality statistics and I can update
you that it's been presented this year
that the Medicare penalties for
readmission have not lowered readmission
rates nationally and in fact since
they've been put in place mortality
rates have gone up so many thought
leaders are really bringing out the
point
that public policy does need to be
linked to improved outcomes and when
they improved outcomes don't occur we
need to really re-evaluate that policy
many hospitals are paying penalties
right now and there's no suggestion that
those penalties are working in terms of
reducing hospitalization so we're at our
first polling question and and a survey
slide will come out to you that will ask
the question that please select which
biomarker do you or your institution
currently used to manage heart failure
patients BNP and terminal probe BNP
collectin 3 or none and I'm hoping the
question will allow you to choose more
than one but I'm going to go ahead as
you tackle that I'm going to go ahead
and and move forward so let's get into
the natural peptides these are hormones
produced by the heart muscle that are
measurable in blood and have been used
to rule out heart failure aid in the
diagnosis of heart failure in cases
where the diagnosis is uncertain and
then they're very powerful in terms of
prognosis and risk stratification this
slide shows the schema of a cardio
myocyte shown on the left in yellow and
then the plasma shown in the right in a
white background showing that
cardiomyocytes both atrial and cardia
monocytes produce pre-pro BNP the gene
for this is coded on chromosome 1 it has
a very rapid up ab regulation sequence
though the heart can produce a lot of
this on demand in response to wall
tension it secretes pre-pro BNP it's
initially cleaved by urine in the cardio
myocyte and then outside the cardio
myocyte cleave by an enzyme called
Corrin into two fragments one is the
inactive and terminal pro BMP fragment
which is 78 Mino acids
the other is the mature BNP fragment
which is 32 amino acids it's very
important to realize that n-terminal Pro
BMP is a much longer half-life 120
minutes compared to BNP which has a
half-life of 20 minutes and terminal Pro
BNP is cleared by the kidneys and into
the urine and does undergo some pro do
proteolytic cleavage BNP is largely
cleared by clearance receptors there are
an also solid organs including the
kidneys BNP is not filtered into the
urine and it also has some clearance
from neutral independence
all the assays for BNP agree that the
upper limit of normal is 100 picograms
for ml for n-terminal Pro B&P there's no
agreement among studies with single
assays or there's no agreement between
different assays of what an upper limit
of normal is as a general rule an upper
limit normal could be viewed as less
than 450 but that's far greater than the
FDA package insert so with n-terminal
Pro BNP it's just really a relative
judgement without hard cut points for
normal versus abnormal BNP it's very
different where we have got a singular
cut point which holds at 100 in all
studies and that was initially shown in
this paper in New England Journal of
Medicine the BMP multinational study
where in 1586 patients who presented to
the emergency room with suspected heart
failure you can see here BNP had an area
under the ROC curve of 0.9 won the cut
point fell right at a hundred picograms
ml and it was a very clear signal that
when patients had symptoms attributable
to a heart layer that BNP was reliably
elevated conversely when heart layer
wasn't present BNP less than 100
reliably ruled out the presence of heart
failure it's been further shown that in
the setting of acute coronary syndromes
where there can be left regular
dysfunction that no matter if their
patient is troponin negative or troponin
positive those with an elevated BMP
value have a much higher mortality at 30
days now the reason for these fatal
cases is that BMP is reflecting large
zones of a scheme
I see really severe left main coronary
lesions or three severe through vessel
coronary disease
large myocardial infarctions
pre-existing left ventricular impairment
systolic or diastolic dysfunction or
renal dysfunction none of these things
are favorable for the patients but the
point is BNP should be measured in
patients with chest pain and acute
coronary syndromes I know I'd bailer we
do this now but several years ago we
didn't it took a long time for everyone
to get caught up with the guidelines in
BNP is a class 1a indication for all
patients with heart failure and all
patients with acute coronary syndromes
now there is a continuum of BNP that you
can think of in patients all of us who
are you know hopefully without heart
failure or perhaps just with a risk
factor for heart failure like
hypertension the BNP should be less than
half of our age so if you're under age
50 hopefully it'll be less than 50
picograms or m/l stage B heart failure
they've been screening studies suggest
for sure BNP be over 20 but in general
BNP can be much higher over a hundred or
so in patients with structural heart
disease stage C symptomatic heart fire B
and P is relatively reliably over a
hundred when patients present to the
clinic it can be 500 to 5,000 with
decompensation we do know about a
quarter of patients with stage C heart
slayer optimally managed can achieve BMP
below 100 and then lastly stage D heart
failure my experiences at the BNP is
typically over a thousand and is not
coming down with therapy there have been
multiple clinical trials using B and P
in the management of patients and has
been shown to be associated to reduction
in mortality if BNP is used in the
outpatient clinic on a regular basis to
help assess where patients are in terms
of their multi drug therapy and its uses
associated with reduced mortality in
this meta-analysis and then importantly
all of these studies that have been
associated with B and P and positive
management outcomes have been
specifically with the BNP
ese and not the n-terminal pro BNP and
in this head-to-head analysis that I
published years ago you can see that BNP
is a tighter dynamic range than
n-terminal Pro BNP but importantly a
much smaller grey zone the grey zone in
BNP could be between 100 and 500 on in
certain cases but with n-terminal Pro
BNP it could be 452 mm and terminal Pro
BMP does not have a stable cut point
from si - si or from study to study and
for that reason it can be used to get as
a general guide but we cannot apply hard
cut points or cutouts to n-terminal Pro
BNP I want to finish with some comments
with respect to collectin 3 this si may
be one that you're not familiar with in
your clinical laboratory but it also is
fda-cleared and is part of the
guidelines for patients with heart
failure what we know is that heart
failure is associated what's called
adverse remodelling and the heart muscle
tissue does have macrophages believe it
or not in heart tissue about two-thirds
of the cells are not cardiomyocytes but
there are other satellite cells such as
macrophages which are resident in heart
tissue and we know that that macrophages
can secrete collectin 3 in response to
various stimuli and the collectin 3 then
stimulates fibroblasts to prolifically
proliferate and and then begin to
secrete pro-collagen 1 for collagen 1
then cross links to mature collagen and
that actually is what causes scar or
fibrosis in heart tissue we do find that
the heart does develop fibrosis the
galectins are normally in tissue and
they're present as important signals
between macrophages and fibroblasts in
order to cause healing so when the skin
is cut and a scar forms it's all
mediated through collectin 3 but in
through galectins
and there's a whole family of them but
in the heart specifically collect in 3
is produced by these resident
macrophages and
and all studies suggest that it's a
maladaptive
of a signal that the collective 3 is
actually pathogenic in the development
of heart failure as a syndrome so let's
get into it what is known about
collectin 3 well it's one of a family of
lectins there's about 11 of these it's
gene is known it's been sequenced and
cloned it's the most up regulated
fibrosis related protein in the
myocardium of the failing heart secreted
primarily by macrophages
it's a paracrine or autocrine signaling
internalized by beta one integrant on
the cell surface of fibroblasts it can
form Penta mears at the cell surface and
activate growth receptors its main
target is mild fibroblasts via
intracellular signaling and this helps
translate the tgf-beta signal to
increase the cell cycle so basically
it's revving up a myofibril blasts and
fibroblasts to secrete pro-collagen one
it's proven to be pathogenic it induces
fibrosis and animal models and it has a
natural inhibitor called ACS dkp this
inhibitor protein is slightly up
regulated by ACE inhibitors as an
example and it's also contained in in
citrus pectin so so eat your oranges and
your citrus fruit is thought to be an
inhibitor of this fibrotic process here
are the data showing that collecting 3
is directly pathogenic in this paper by
Sharma in what was done in this study is
that animals had the pericardium opened
and the heart was basically bathed in
synthetic collectin 3 and what was shown
is that that collectin those animals
were collected 3 was induced developed
heart failure at a much higher rate
compared to those who didn't what we've
shown in the prevent study is that a
normal population of collecting 3 level
settles in around ten to eleven
nanograms per ml there isn't a hard
declaration of normal in the available
assays on the market but this
population-based study suggests that
collected three goes up a little bit
with age but very importantly shown in
the Framingham Heart Study that
individuals in midlife who's collected
threes were over fifteen point four that
they had a markedly increased risk for
the development of heart failure
compared to those with lower collect in
three levels and so my understanding the
data is that this is the most powerful
predictor for the future development of
heart failure that we have as a blood
test and it's its prognostic ability to
anticipate heart failure in the future
is very strong it is indicated to be
used in patients with established heart
failure based on these data from the
Coache study where as you can see
through a range of collecting three the
overall risks for death and
hospitalization are progressively higher
now granted all patients with heart
failure even at lower levels of
collectin three have increased risks of
these events but you can see at over
collected three over twenty five point
nine would be considered very high and
at that level there's a considerable
short-term risk of death which is even
greater than that of hospitalization now
it's been shown from two trials where
the data where merged that collected
three doesn't move very much in heart
failure patients it moves it as much as
a fifteen percent change when measured
nine months apart so it doesn't change
very much but when it does increase the
prognosis is worse as shown in that
green line and when it does decrease the
prognosis is better
however collecting three in my practice
is something i typically measure on the
initial consultation it may be a year
later but it's not a test that's
amenable to very frequent testing unlike
BNP values which can be measured in
studies up to every six weeks and show
value now collected three has been shown
an experimental model spree related
renal fibrosis and in this study these
animals have what's called a ureteral
outlet obstruction model that in the
wild-type as shown in the left-hand
panel
collectin 3 is markedly up regulated and
there's collagen deposition but when we
knock out an animal for collectin 3 and
they can't produce it there's
considerably less fibrosis that's
developed so we do know in kidney
disease that collectin 3 is playing a
role and we published a paper several
years ago suggesting that probably
there's simultaneous cardiac and renal
fibrosis that's occurring and is
explaining some of the chronic cardio
real syndromes where patients have
simultaneous heart and kidney failure
the collectin 3 may be playing a
pathogenic role we do know from the
Framingham Heart Study that collectin 3
is related to a reduction in gulmira
filtration rate over time meaning
progressive chronic kidney disease so
just like it anticipates heart failure
it anticipates chronic kidney disease
but it does not predict albumin area so
remember for chronic kidney disease we
still need to measure this here in
creatinine calculate the estimated
glomerular filtration rate and also
measure the urine albumin accrediting
ratio collected 3 does have this
important a relationship the cut point
for progression of chronic kidney
disease in Framingham is very similar
for the progression of heart failure
it's greater than 15 nanograms per ml
well I want to now move on to the
conclusions and we'll have some more
questions and finish by saying that
heart failure is a clinical syndrome
which is amenable to the use of in vitro
diagnostics metric peptides indicate
increased wall tension both BNP and
n-terminal pro BNP in my view B and P
offers a more interpretable framework
with a teachable algorithm and has had
positive studies with respect to
management outcomes
the same is not true for any terminal
probe EMP collectin three is immediate
or cardiac fibrosis and it's measurable
in plasma and it is a prognostic aid in
heart failure BNP and collectin three
can be used in assessing the response to
therapy BNP is a lot more responsive
than collecting three but these and
other novel markers may become targets
for disease management in the future I
think they clearly have a role and of
help clinicians since their introduction
now the naturai peptides being
introduced nearly twenty years ago so
I'll stop here
and we'll turn it over to our next
polling question
Thank You dr. McCulloh for your
presentation a quick reminder to our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click that send button dr.
McCall will answer as many questions as
time permits let's take a look at our
incoming questions already from our
audience members our first question dr.
McCullough is is there a difference in
incidence of arrhythmia in reduced
versus preserved EF mortality
differences yes there are that's a good
question the risk of fatal arrhythmias
is a higher with heart failure with
reduced ejection fraction and it's for
that reason when the ejection fraction
is less than 35% that implantable
cardioverter SAR indicated and that's
the reason why I CDs are used in heart
failure with reduced ejection fraction
and they largely are not used in heart
failure with preserved ejection fraction
thank you very much our neck
question is are there any other heart
failure biomarkers beyond natural addict
peptides and collectin 3 yes there's a
third biomarker called st 2 and that
stands for the suppressor of to merge
Anisa t too much less is known about
this it was originally discovered in the
cancer literature it turns out that the
cells inside the left ventricle and the
aorta cough what Rex Creed s T 2 and it
acts as a decoy protein interfering with
a immune signaling between the immune
system and cardiomyocytes but much less
is known about st 2 it appears to be
prognostic in heart failure and in
general what we've learned a disease is
that these tests are very complementary
to one another they help us understand
different aspects of heart failure so I
anticipate st2 will be used in
complement to BNP as well as collecting
three
thank you for that and thank you to our
audience members for submitting these
great questions our next question is
what is the percentage of Galacta 3 used
for heart failure versus BNP ante Pro
BNP my understanding is the majority of
testing is really with B and P or
n-terminal Pro BNP and it comes out of
the emergency room which is appropriate
because all patients who present to the
emergency room with suspected heart
failure should have one of those tests
done collectin 3 is used less often and
in my view is more of an office tool in
the initial office evaluation of a
patient with heart failure where again I
order a BNP but I also order a collectin
3 and I'll say in my practice I do also
order an st 2 I order a fourth protein
that everyone's familiar with and it is
in the heart failure guidelines and
that's troponin cardiac troponin at our
Hospital we measure cardiac troponin I
but either troponin I or T can be used
so there are four guidelines recommended
tests for the office evaluation of heart
failure and they are BNP or n-terminal
Pro BNP collectin 3 st 2 and cardiac
troponin
Thank You dr. McCulloh and which of
these biomarkers do you currently use in
your practice to manage patient
therapies what change are you looking
for to confirm are working or not work
but the most successful biomarker in
practice for management has been BNP and
we know there that when BNP doubles from
wherever it is the patient clearly has
worsened and we know if B and P is
reduced by 50% the patient clearly has
gotten better and I think we have to use
those wide boundaries to really
understand B and P in guiding therapy so
if I have a patient in the office whose
BNP is doubled that's a pretty strong
signal to the patient we need to get
that patient in and adjust their
diuretics often times give them a short
course of an increased diuretic to get
them back to a good volume status
conversely if the patient's BNP is
dropped by 50% that's a signal that we
probably can down
titrate diuretics and make some other
adjustments maybe we have more room with
respect to blood pressure we can
increase some of their disease modifying
therapies like an ACE inhibitor and ARB
beta blocker
thank you and why have the readmission
rates not gone down
despite penalty to the hospital's that
is a terrific question but right now
there are not good sources of
explanation for that observation but my
personal concern is what's happening is
that there has been a great effort to
try to reduce these admissions in by
doing so we may be shortening the
patient's hospital stay or we may be
prompting more surveillance of symptoms
and patients coming right back into the
hospital for more treatment it's pretty
clear that our therapy that we apply in
the hospital does not modify the disease
we simply in a sense kind of tune-up
heart failure and then patients can come
right back in so our treatment is not
durable and we don't have any
fda-approved proven inpatient therapies
and for that reason it would make sense
that we even if we're penalized we still
can't make headway in this disease state
there were prior studies that that I
think mislead us that suggested that
some of these heart failure readmissions
were avoidable and right now the data
suggests that they're not
and dr. McCoy is there any evidence of
improved prognosis using collecting
three in cardiac fibrosis patients yes
it's clear that when collecting three
drops over the course of a year by more
than 15% the patient is on a good course
and sometimes we see patients have
dramatic improvements with some newer
medications one of them is called
entresto which is a drug that's superior
to ace inhibitors in the treatment of
heart failure sometimes we see patients
who have forms of non ischemic
cardiomyopathy where they markedly
improve with a whole constellation of
drugs including entrust Oh
evidence-based beta blockers the use of
another new drug called errata being
that in that setting if collecting three
really reduces and takes a good downward
trajectory over time then patients may
have prolonged survival all the data
suggests that's the case so that's good
news when we see collecting three
dropping
thank you and what is the cost and time
frame receiving for results using
Galacta 3 how can we make it more
widespread I don't have the answer on
costs because the laboratories all have
you know their own contracts and
techniques on doing these assays some
laboratories do them in-house
some of them send them out I can tell
you in our practice environment at
Baylor that these are a very minor part
of the cost picture for patients so
they're much less expensive than getting
additional imaging or doing additional
testing the lab is our best value if you
will the use of laboratories in general
is lagging across many quality metrics
so for instance you know diabetics do
not get enough hemoglobin a1c testing we
have data that in adults and children we
don't do enough lipid profile testing
and then as the question implies we
don't use enough evidence based testing
in heart failure and acute coronary
syndromes so I think we have a long ways
to go to use these important laboratory
tools to their optimum capabilities
that's one of the reasons why we have
seminars like this
thank you and I want to thank our
audience again for their wonderful
participation or incoming questions are
there any other biomarkers apart from
collecting three for patients suffering
with cardiac fibrosis now outside of the
again the four evidence based markers
are BNP or internal probe EMP collectin
3s T 2 and cardiac troponin those are
the four that are FDA cleared and that
are in the accha 2013 guidelines there
are many more biomarkers that are under
research evaluation right now and that
list is quite long of tests that are
under research that are measurable in
the research setting but all of those
will will have to be borne out in
studies that show that they're both
accurate that they're precise and that
they you know have a clinical utility
most commonly the clinical utility that
would win an FDA clearance would be
prognosis and so far beyond the four
I've mentioned none have additionally
won an FDA prognostic claim
now does collectin have to be used for
other cardiac markers to give diagnosis
for HS no collectin 3 on its own it has
important prognostic value I can tell
you my practice I almost always order it
with the other evidence-based biomarkers
but it alone and by itself has
prognostic value and I think uniquely
collectin 3 is the strongest of all the
markers in terms of predicting the
future development of heart failure in
patients in the middle age and so it
does
collectin 3 is provided on a advanced
laboratory panel that I use in my office
practice and so in that application it
does give me an important window to the
future in terms of future risk of heart
failure thank you and this next question
is a two-part question in a patient with
diastolic dysfunction due to radiation
show a higher collectin 3 or is
collectin 3 equally as important in
preserved and reduced ejection fraction
yes my experiences I collected 3 will be
elevated in forms of radiation in
chemotherapy induced cardiomyopathy and
yes it is a prognostic and elevated in
both types of heart failure preserved
and reduced ejection fraction
and is collecting three values change
your management of the patient and if so
how
yeah I think that the collecting three
values this is an extension beyond
what's in the current guidelines are
beyond the FDA package insert but I can
just tell you my practice pattern is
that the data suggests that collecting
the three markedly elevated patients in
my view need intensification of their
medical therapy along the lines of ACE
inhibitors angiotensin receptor
antagonists the new combination of l
Sartain and sec u Bertrille and then
mineralocorticoid receptor antagonist
spironolactone or a planner known and
there are have been some prospective
studies that the drugs that I just
mentioned that they work optimally in
helping attenuate the progression of
fibrosis so when collect and three is
elevated I'm thinking about cardiac
fibrosis and I'm thinking about that
whole line of medications which is very
very different than other lines of
medications we can use in heart failure
thank you and dr. McLaws how is a chess
with preserved EF diagnosed heart
failure with preserved ejection fraction
clinically looks very similar to heart
failure with reduced ejection fraction
the patients have fatigue they have
shortness of breath they have evidence
of fluid in the lungs and they have
peripheral edema it's just that when we
do the cardiac echocardiogram the
ejection fraction is normal and many
times there will reliant on the BNP that
the BNP or the n-terminal Pro BNP helps
establish the diagnosis now the BNP in
general won't be as high as those with
reduced ejection fraction but it will be
well above that 100 picogram per
milliliter cut point so if I see a
patient who is short of breath they have
pulmonary edema
peripheral edema and they have a BNP of
500 that basically clinches the
diagnosis of heart failure with
preserved ejection fraction
such McLaws you discuss the differences
between NT pro BNP and BNP biomarkers
and we've seen discussions and concerns
surrounding Gliss isolated samples in
each F patients and NT probe EMPs
inability to cross-react with these
samples can you comment on the frequency
and impact of glossy elated samples that
end their impact of accuracy of
diagnosis well let me just state that
you're all proteins in the human body
can undergo glycosylation so for
instance I mentioned everyone on the
phone is familiar with glycosylated
hemoglobin or hemoglobin a1c we measure
that but albumin can get glycosylated as
well as the question points out that
naturally peptides can get glycosylated
what I understand about it is that both
of these peptides a BMP and n-terminal
Pro BNP are sufficiently stable over
time in blood that they're measurable
they're measurable from stored samples
and from ship samples so from that
perspective that the that the values
have certainly been vetted in
prospective clinical studies
despite some degree of glycosylation
beyond that I referred to the laboratory
directors who are more facile with
information with respect to stability
and the role that glycosylation will
play with respect to si standards guides
just that that technical knowledge is
beyond my my realm of expertise
now would you say that BNP is better
than NT Pro BMP is it better in patients
with kidney diseases the guidelines
position both of those markers as being
an equal choice but my personal opinion
based on the head-to-head data that I've
published and on my clinical experience
suggests that I think BNP is the
superior test because of all the
different manufacturer assays calibrate
to a 100 picogram per no litre cut point
and the observation that BNP has less
renal interference than n terminal
probiem P now in the setting of
RealPlayer BNP does go up but it's not
as highly dependent on renal function as
n-terminal probe BNP both can be
measured in the setting of kidney
disease but we have to reset our cut
points with BNP we know for instance in
the setting of chronic kidney disease
that the cut point really is probably
about 200 Peter grams for ml that's for
patients who have an elevated serum
creatinine but are not on dialysis for
dialysis patients we know that that BNP
level even in the absence of heart
failure will be about 800 picograms per
mo with n terminal probe E&P in the
setting of non dialysis clinic kidney
disease there really is a substantial
range of values that I don't think
n-terminal Pro BNP is is really
interpretable and then on patients on
dialysis I would not suggest that anyone
have an n-terminal probiem PTI oh I I
don't think it can be interpreted
thank you and I want to remind our
audience members that any question is
not answered today will be answered via
email we have time for a couple more
questions our next question is are B and
P and NT Pro B&P used in the same way
example the same cutoff for both HS with
preserved EF and HS with reduced EF no
they're not I can tell you that with BNP
and Hart's layer with reduced ejection
fraction the cut point is a hundred
picograms for ml and there probably is
an uncertain tone from 100 to 500 where
we could find some cases to debate over
500 all experts agree that that's very
consistent with heart failure in heart
failure with preserved ejection fraction
that there's a tighter dynamic range and
again the cut point is still 104 normal
however once we're above 100 that
becomes increasingly consistent with a
diagnosis of heart failure with
preserved ejection fraction we don't see
levels nearly as high as we do with
heart failure with reduced ejection
fraction with n terminal probiem P
there's really no good guidance with
respect to the range the range could be
as low as 125 picograms for ml as a cut
point all the way up to well over 2000
as a cut point so in terminal probiem P
has to be used as just kind of a
relative guide and is not amenable to
cut points or cannot discern between
heart failure with reduced or preserved
ejection fraction
thank you for that and how does B and P
actually affect HF
well BNP is secreted and it relaxes
blood vessels so it relaxes attention in
the left ventricle all of that all
that's thought to be favorable and heart
failure and it stimulates the kidneys to
excrete salt and water and so it's
diuretic and so that's favorable but
what the listener should appreciate is
that there's been exhaustive studies of
synthetic BNP made and given back to
humans and we can achieve about a plasma
concentration of about 3000 picograms in
ml and while patients feel better while
getting the BNP infusion it is not
reduced mortality or reduced
hospitalization so we we think BNP is
probably better as a blood test
indicating what's going on but it's not
a very powerful form of therapy
thank you and what specific pathways in
patients causes increase in BNP the the
major cause of increased BMP is wall
tension so in the inside of the heart
when there's more tension as the heart
begins to fail that tension on the
cardiomyocytes and the full thickness of
the of the heart tissue stimulates the
cardiomyocytes to start producing the
hormone so the muscle cells in the heart
are not only muscle cells but they're
also endocrine cells and in response to
wall tension they produce BMP
thank you very much dr. McCulloh our
next and final question that we have
time for today we have noticed lympho
sheets excuse me
windows assist reactive lymphocytes in
some of our code STEMI patients is there
a connection between limps and heart
failure well there's definitely an
immune reaction in the setting of acute
coronary syndromes and heart failure for
sure so it's understood for instance
that there can be a white blood cell
count elevation in the setting of an
acute coronary syndrome and in fact in
the state of a heart attack after about
four days there's quite a few
granulocytes and some lymphocytes that
are seen in the heart tissue itself as
we're getting patients more prompt
treatment for myocardial infarction is
probably less of an immune response but
as the question implies there is a link
between the immune system and the
cardiovascular system both in acute
coronary syndromes and heart failure and
so that future link between these two
systems is really being explored from
both a diagnostic and therapeutic
perspective
dr. McCall we actually have time for one
more question and it's a great question
to close with based upon your clinical
expertise what do you believe in the
future of what do you believe in the
future of heart failure and biomarkers
it's a two-part question and what areas
need improvement or research to improve
patient care
my future of you in heart failure since
we have so many therapies particularly
heart Slayer with reduced ejection
fraction is that the future is what's
called personalized medicine that will
measure a whole array of biomarkers in
heart failure patients and then we're
going to tailor the medical therapy to
the biomarker configuration that each
patient has we've already attempted one
small trial in this area and continuing
to work in this area and I think I think
therapy can be tailored to what the
biomarker elevation configuration is in
each patient and hopefully that will
lead to improved outcomes what we found
out now that there's so many drugs in
heart failure
that we can't use them all at the
maximum doses so we have to prioritize
one drug or another and we have to
prioritize not only the drug but also
the dose and the only way to do that the
rate limiting step is typically blood
pressure and tolerability of these drugs
the only way to do it is to be guided by
biomarkers so I see that as the as the
short-term futures personalized medicine
long term I think certain biomarkers
will be determined to be directly
pathogenic and those directly pathogenic
biomarkers will be subject to therapies
that lower them to improve heart failure
outcomes like LDL cholesterol is
directly pathogenic in coronary heart
disease we directly lower LDL
cholesterol we improve outcomes
just like hemoglobin a1c is a very good
proxy for the pathogenesis of
hyperglycemia in organ disease and we
lower hemoglobin a1c we improve outcomes
I think we're going to find some of
these pathogenic markers
future one of them may be collecting
three right now and if anti collect and
three therapies are developed it's
possible they can improve outcomes but I
I see that as the future biomarkers
really have a promising role and heart
failure as a as a syndrome and I'll let
that be the last word and let you close
it out
Thank You dr. McCollum thank you very
much for your important research I'd
also like to thank the audience for
their participation today and for
joining us on this webinar and I'd like
to thank our sponsor Abbott for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through September 2018 lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye